zusammen
[Musik]
ist
dann wollen wir noch mehr
wenn hier eine
[Musik]
gibt es nun eine kleine prise
ja jetzt schon fakten über drogen pacult
ok
dann um alles was trocken ist drin
[Musik]
alle trockenen zutaten hierzu gaben hier
alles war schon drin
und groß
und hilft geliefert rompf
[Musik]
muss bei uns rein immer auf jeden fall
immer fans oder im kuchen
und was ist das geheimrezept
[Musik]
wir warten die sehnsucht nach berlin
entfernt sind die kann man nicht hin wir
können mit dem große pläne oder wir
können auch diese
müssen oder die
weißen oder die hier gehen
[Musik]
die sind so groß
und was sagst du jetzt schon mal zu
unserem ab ich
glaube wir haben sogar genug teig ich
weiß lächeln als er mit hier einfach
250 gramm milch buttermilch 150 gramm
summen nennen 150 gramm zucker
mehl und dann könnt ihr gerne noch
backpulver oder nach unter zu viel
allerdings mag mail benutzt da ist schon
drin aber ansonsten halben themen durch
die fakten vor und helfen sie mit natron
und was noch
[Musik]
da ist jedenfalls sonntag in der mitte
und drumherum
[Musik]
ich nehme einfach das hier
weil ich hier mit keine papiere
platzieren kellereien deswegen ja
wenn wir papierfähnchen benutzen
brauchen wir keinen wachsen aber bei
denen geht brauchen wir
da gucken war einfach klar und ich
scheint den ofen auf
[Musik]
die
buslinien
[Musik]
dürfen
dankeschön
[Musik]
nichts vergessen
was ist das beste am backen
und naschen
[Musik]